[Music]
hey you wanna see a movie where Oh God
where's she putting that hand yep we
have a new Netflix horror starring
Allison Williams nope not that one the
perfection tells the tale of Charlotte
Wilmore a cello prodigy who must give up
her dreams of being a famous cellist to
take care of her dying mother and to be
honest I was into this movie for the
first 20 minutes or so until this
happened okay you know for that but
let's rewind for a moment and let me try
to explain what I didn't like about this
movie for those of you who have no
intention of watching it after the death
of her mother Charlotte goes in search
of her mentor Anton who she studied with
at the prestigious back-off Academy at
the Shanghai opera she's introduced to
Elizabeth Welles also a mentee of
Anton's she's arguably the most famous
cellist in the world
they have a romantic tryst head off into
the rural outskirts of China and
Charlotte convinces Liz to chop off her
hand oh and it gets worse which brings
me to my point this movie makes no sense
the first 40 minutes takes place in
China where we follow Charlotte who kind
of aimlessly meanders about she's there
to see if she can rejoin Anton but 10
minutes in decides to galavant with Liz
and seems to forget why she was there to
begin with this all leads to the
climactic midpoint where we find out
Charlotte has drugged Liz so that she'll
hallucinate and chop off her own hand
the amount of Hoops Charlotte has to go
through to get Liz to chop off her hand
are staggering first she is to drugger
accentuate the drugs effects with
alcohol steal a butcher knife which will
later be used to cut off her hand plant
the seed that bugs are on her when they
get on the bus Google how to improvise a
tourniquet have the bus driver desert
them and then finally have her cut off
her own arm but the worst part of this
whole thing is the fact Charlotte is
even doing this in the first place we're
kind of led to believe this might be a
jealousy thing but as we'll later find
out Anton runs a child pedophile ring
where he rapes his protege is in order
to make them the perfect musician but it
gets worse instead of going after Anton
Charlotte decides to go after the rape
victim Liz chopping off her only mean
of a livelihood in her mind Charlotte is
doing Liz a favor so that she'll come to
the realization she's been brainwashed
and apparently the only way this can be
done is by chopping off her hand after
that Charlotte just kind of goes back to
her life and I was like great movies
over but no no no Liz goes back to Anton
and is shunned by him because she has no
hand so in an effort to get back into
his good book she decides to kidnap
Charlotte not confusing at all
how is kidnapping Charlotte gonna make
Anton magically accept you Anton hasn't
given a [ __ ] about Charlotte and he
never went after her after she left to
take care of her mom anyways now that
she's here Anton decides well guess we
might as well abuse her shaming her up
in Jimmy Choos to perform a task called
the perfection if she can play a piece
perfectly without missing a note he'll
let her go
if she fails him and the other teachers
will you know even his wife is in on it
but liz is actually working with
Charlotte and she drugs the other
teachers we get this flashback of her
breaking into Charlotte's house and
tasering her only for Liz to tell her
she was right all along chopping up her
hand made her see how evil Anton was you
could have just rang the doorbell and
been like hey girl
you were right so they end up basically
amputating Anton also taking out his
eyes and tongue forcing him to listen to
the two of them play the cello as a duet
with their two working arms now yes it
is kind of cool and [ __ ] up but it
makes no sense first to fully amputate a
dude like this and make sure he doesn't
die you need professional surgeons
second several months would have needed
to pass in order for him to get in this
state also where did the bodies of the
other teachers go is no one looking for
them where are the other students who
supposedly live in this building so in
this movie we have a main character who
doesn't really do anything a rape victim
was punished for being the victim of
abuse characters driven by ridiculous
motivations and a scene where a stump
almost goes up a woman's hoo-ha I give
this movie 5 chopped hands out of 10 hey
thanks for watching everyone if you like
these types of videos please let me know
by keeping the video a like comment and
subscribe I've got a video of Doom
Patrol coming out soon which you haven't
seen
highly recommend until next time
remember daddy loves you very much